my internet do you like video games do
you like Japanese role-playing games
have you been asking for a HD we release
of final fantasy 7 of course you have
that's all we've heard on gamespot com
for the past but I found fantasy 7
kombat 9 97 7 yeah a year before the big
one year before 98 Jeremy Janie Peter
bran you guys play fine I'm funny 7 back
in the day and we finally gosh i
remember back at the PlayStation
experience we got like yeah we're gonna
rerelease final fantasy 7 but looks the
exact same and everyone was super not
happy birthday yeah this year t3 they
showed a trailer with some CG ass Cloud
Strife happening they're remaking fine
57 yes hey art yeah I'm an HD thing
they're just gonna go whole hog on this
yeah which could mean a lot of different
things right i mean a Alexa talked to I
think tats you know more of the director
at e3 and he was saying like yeah the
story you know that story already exists
why would we want to put the same story
out there it's going to change loss yeah
yeah but well I mean think about it this
way so a lot of people got upset when
they announced this they're like you
know we want our game to be untouched
it's this canonical piece of gaming
history and we want it you know to look
beautiful and to be touched up but
essentially to be an untouched game but
from where I'm standing it's kind of
like why would you want to play like I
played that game several times I
shouldn't even ask question why would
you wanna play the same game again but
like don't you like if they're gonna
bring in all these beautiful creative
people to like work on this amazing
project wouldn't want them to put new
things in it and like reimagine it
without corrupting the like central core
of final fantasy 7 I don't know man i'm
not a big fan of fantasy fan but if I
think of like an HD remake of any of my
like big and nostalgia pull a game yes
don't [ __ ] my old game first that's more
my brain goes straight away so i don't
know like that you can still go back and
play a final fantasy 7 the remake will
never negate the existence right your
original so you will always have that to
go back to what i am excited about is
seeing stuff like this right we're
looking at Midgar here which there are
the slums of midgar I think it's sector
seven or sector nine and and you know
these is sort of back in the day when
you played this game you got a real
sense of the identity of the environment
the people who live there
is it because of the pretty good
storytelling you know some of the
dialogue was really campy but you really
got to know the environment and the
society and those are the things I'm
interested in seeing like you know
elevated to new levels with greater
attention to detail just you know better
framing and composition before there
were fixed cameras for the most part
yeah just text bubbles for everything
yes Lee so yeah I mean I'm I'm nervous
as hell about hearing you know I guess
you could have heard cloud stripes Boyce
if you watch advent children hmm you
know the movie they made but I sure did
yeah I was pretty that's really all it
was yeah and people are worried that
they're going to be like elements from
that you know incorporated into seven
and seven was so popular that you know
Evan children and some of the other
games that even came after it really
springboard it off at success but never
really stayed true to like the core that
made it Falcon 7 so special it exploited
that game and that's and that the
identity of all the characters to come
up with new stuff so like I just hope it
doesn't do that in just a reality of one
of these games that if you remake a game
like this like going back and playing
that game and seeing like how much
detail as in each area and how quickly
the plot moves from like place to place
the place like if you frame that game in
a fully realized CG world it just kind
of wouldn't work like it would just feel
really strange like the area that you
play in in that in that town you're in
earlier hey buddy might seem really like
it's like if you had like are you saying
like if you had the original resident
evil but Yuri made it in the resin evil
4 engine you'd be like walking around
those environments but you wouldn't have
those like fixed camera thank you were
the hell at the ocean would your dream a
casual risen but that would work
sensious Christo I feel like that would
work because it's such a small area I'm
saying is like when they made these
games in the past they only had the
ability to run every small thing but
they kind of obfuscated 'add they made
you think that was part of a real world
right whereas the way we make things
feel like real worlds today as we make
make a real world for sure so well I
mean that's that's why this is an
exciting opportunity at least in my
opinion cuz like i love final fantasy 7
man i played that game like when it came
out and I was a kid and like I struggle
through my computer couldn't run it i
would like to lose my save data all the
time but like that game was so worth it
because it was it was such an insane
narrative experience that it's like
reading a book like my brain filled in
so much of that game because that game
didn't fill in a lot of things for you
because it's
you know it's an older game they like
you said they the fixed camera angles
there were things that I wondered about
and like why can't I go over there and
see what's over there I'm excited to see
you know all of these people who are so
excited and passionate about this
project create those like missing spots
and letting go back and fill in and
flesh out the world a little more
there's the danger though of them
actually having the time in the budget
to do that or because if you look at
something like final fantasy 13 like
yeah you know that's a big budget final
fantasy game that they were working on
for very long time and you look at the
sort of locales that are there yeah
they're pretty sparse like there's a
couple NPCs it doesn't feel like a
living environment the way I think so
much of final fantasy 7 did right but
also that game that world is huge like
there are you know when you end up
playing 7080 hours into that game you
end up in little villages you know like
forests on the middle of nowhere they
have these little pockets of like hidden
areas it's it's hard for me to imagine
how that structure is going to work for
something like a modern Final Fantasy
game with the way that they design it
these days because the last few have
been linear as hell they haven't made
like a large open map Final Fantasy game
in such a long time apart from 14 but
that doesn't really count so for
something like final fantasy 7 we just
saw some footage there the the one they
showed off the PlayStation experience
the sort of the idea of HD up the old
game but if they're making this new game
in a new engine in the world like what
does that mean in terms of new content
you just like add a couple of more mini
games to go saw so do you add like
entire new parts of the world do you
have to change the story to enable that
I don't think they need to to add to it
very much apart from the world building
aspect of it I don't think there needs
to be more content because you played I
mean the 70-80 our game that's that's
quite a bit of content already I mean
one thing they could do depending on how
they manage the the new combat because
it probably will horse I doubt it'll be
turn-based it could be but the materia
system made the game so interesting
right and how you could have one bit of
materia and raise it over the course of
dozens of hours to finally unlock some
crazy things so you combine that with
other things you've had a similar
adventure with and to even add a couple
new material to make that interesting I
think would be enough for a lot of
people to get really excited about
playing it again that's going to be an
interesting thing when they when they go
whatever they do to the combat Jeremy
are you in favor of them changing it up
or do
like classic like for Phoenix tan for 50
seconds or I I recent the final fantasy
nine is one of the only ones that I
didn't play doubt if like the golden age
or whatever the hell and Alexa was like
you have to go play it so that was like
my homework so I went home and I start
playing that game and I really liked it
I got pretty far into it but I have to
say that the like old like active time
comment like filling the meters and
stuff like it worked so great for me
back in the day and there's just
something like I just don't have time
for that or like something or like work
an emergency or it feels like antiquated
but like God if the one thing they have
to fix is the summit animations cuz like
anyone who's played final fantasy 7 you
like seven nights of the round and then
you go like microwave a burrito because
it's gonna be like that in it until
you're doing anything again so like I
mean they have to do something with a
combat I just I don't know how it's
gonna play out because I think it has to
be turn-based like I but I don't know
how it's gonna be you would think so I
mean Final Fantasy 15 that game
initially it lets you control multiple
party members now they've whittle it
down to one because that's just that's
essentially what you have to do when
you're doing real-time combat like this
with a party your party is just there to
support you and I think the combat in
the game overall will absolutely suffer
if you do not have control over your
entire team and doing that as a single
player you might yeah you might need
that active Time battle or turn-based
combat you know system that we're used
to you know do you how would you feel
about them adding all this stuff to the
game and then just having like some
weird ass classic mode that you hit just
like lets you do all the old stuff I
would love that yeah it's not a bad idea
at all yeah I mean I I'm very worried
about this remake but I'm very excited
that they're actually they have the
balls to give it a shot right me I mean
that's why I'm excited because like sure
there's the risk of them [ __ ] it up
in this just being like some snafu in
gaming history and everyone is so pissed
but like if they don't take that risk
they don't have the opportunity to
potentially make something words like oh
whoa like if I tell my kids to play
final fantasy 7 i'm gonna be like play
this one yeah i mean like that may not
be I feel like that won't be the case
but I really hope it is you never know
yeah last question for both you guys I'm
gonna put you on the spot Jeremy when
will we see this remake of Final Fantasy
said Oh God uh year and quarter but when
Atlantis rises from the sea I have no
idea got a quote you gotta get one I'm
gonna
go back we're gonna go back in the in
the b-roll we're gonna back in the
archive sorry for this in a couple of
years oh maybe in a couple of months kyu
won 20-17 I have no idea ok that's
ambitious q3 2019 oh [ __ ] really yeah q
33 19 yeah okay I mean [ __ ] look how
long has taken him to make the other
final fantasy games right all right
we'll see we'll see you for all still
around then I'll be dead yeah your
problem I project you live a very
entertaining rich life you'll probably
razor's edge me I'm gonna catch up